mais une écharpe sinon tu vas tomber
malade toutes les mamans du monde nous
ont déjà donné ce conseil
et ça a l'air vrai il suffit de passer
une soirée dehors sans son manteau et on
se retrouve le lendemain cloué au lit
on vit alors qu'on a attrapé froid une
expression qu'on retrouve dans plein de
langues pourtant c'est pas logique
le froid c'est juste du froid quand vous
ouvrez votre frigo tombez pas malade
les glaçons dans votre coca ne sont pas
de dangereuses armes bactériologiques
non comme vous le savez c'est les
microbes et les virus qui sont les
responsables
mais du coup pourquoi ray apparaît style
brusquement en hiver alors qu'il
semblait avoir disparu en été
la statistiques le prouvent en tombe
cinq fois plus malade en hiver alors où
se cachent les virus pendant nos
vacances
vous allez voir la question est beaucoup
plus intéressante est complexe en a
l'air
quels sont les effets du froid sur
l'organisme le froid a sur votre corps
de très nombreux effets secondaires que
vous ignoriez ceci dit avant de
commencer coupons court à l'idée reçue
non votre corps ne refroidit pas vous
rester avoue 37 degrés habituels à 35
degrés vous seriez déjà en hypothermie
ce froid quand même vous demander de
l'énergie et diminuer l'efficacité de
votre corps on a inoculé la grippe à des
souris les une place au chaud les autres
à 12 degrés résultats celles au chaud on
produit beaucoup plus de messagers
chimiques appelant les défenses
immunitaires
la raison n'est pas parfaitement
comprises mais on a remarqué que le
froid avait en effet jusqu'aux cellules
en retardant leur apoptose à savoir leur
auto-destruction cantal sont infectés
par un virus
- d'autodestruction égale plus de
diffusion les virus eux mêmes deviennent
plus résistants au froid
la coque qui les protègent se durcit
c'est le cas pour le rhume ou la gastro
là encore c'est une idée reçue de croire
que mettre votre masque au frigo
mathieu et névé russe n'en voulait
conserver l'explication de l'efficacité
redoutable de l'hiver et pourtant à
chercher ailleurs ici dans votre nez
l'air froid que vous inspirez va
provoquer plein de réactions en chaîne
les points qui le tapis ce sont
d'excellents de barrière contre les
microbes mais exposé au froid ils ont
tendance à se ralentir et de facto
bloquant - les agressions même effet sur
le mucus mêmes effets sur la circulation
sanguine
quand l'extrémité de vaudois glace et
deviennent tout blanc c'est que le corps
il en voit beaucoup moins de 100 et bien
ça vaut aussi pour votre nez le problème
c'est que le sang permet de faire
voyager les signaux chimiques et les
défenses immunitaires
il y en a - votre corps est prompte à se
défendre notons quand même que l'idée
d'attraper froid n'est pas totalement un
mythe c'est juste que vous n'êtes pas
vraiment malade quand les froids atteint
vos poumons savent aller brûler comme
quand vous laissez un glaçon trop
longtemps sur notre peau voilà pourquoi
vous toussez et vous vous sentez mal
mais pas suffisant pour vous clouer au
lit
vous devez être infecté par un virus ou
un micro pour ça d'ailleurs neuf fois
sur dix c'est à cause d'un virus
et si le froid était bon pour notre
santé vous connaissez peut-être iceman
de son vrai nom louis prof c'est un vrai
maître dans la cohabitation avec le
froid adepte des records en tout genre
il a déjà presque tenu deux heures dans
un bar rempli de gaz il a aussi fait un
semi marathon au pôle nord pis nu et en
short dans la même tenue
il a aussi escalader l'everest là il a
rajouté des petites chaussures pour
protéger ses petits petons ou des
cailloux tranchant les scientifiques se
sont donc penchés sur l'origine de son
pouvoir
ils ont découvert que grâce à sa méthode
de respiration il était capable de
réguler lui même la température de sa
peau et sa production de chaleur
il propose même des stages pour faire
comme lui l'idée que s'exposer au froid
est bénéfique pour la santé ne date pas
d'hier
les peuples scandinaves se baigner
traditionnellement dans les eaux
glaciales pour se renforcer
les premiers romain avec des termes
froide appelé frigidarium et même les
égyptiens ont pratiqué des traitements
par le froid
ce que la découverte d'un et papyrus
lieu de 3500 ans ce qui nous tue pas
nous rend plus fort c'est aujourd'hui ce
qu'on appelle le principe de leur mère
quand on regarde l'effet d'une substance
en fonction de la dose administrée on
obtient une courbe qui ressemble à ça on
peut voir que les faibles doses peuvent
avoir un effet bénéfique
c'est un principe proche de la
mithridatisation prix mitri dmitri
darrat
c'est un principe proche de la
mithridatisation d'en vider tout est
poison
rien n'est poison c'est la dose qui fait
le poison quand vous vous exposez à une
substance nocive à faible dose vous ne
tombez pas malade
répétez cette opération de très
nombreuses fois et vous finirez est
immunisé à cette substance même à plus
forte dose avec leur mère en s'exposant
de manière contrôlée à des agressions
les effets sur la santé peuvent être
très bénéfiques et ici l'agresseur c'est
le froid même si les mécanismes
biologiques
ce ne sont pas encore tous compris on
peut observer des choses bénéfiques
comme l'augmentation de super globules
blancs comme les lymphocytes t
cytotoxiques le froid diminue aussi le
mécanisme de l'inflammation
ça vous pouvez vous en rendre compte
très facilement le premier conseil quand
on se tord la cheville et que ça gonfle
c'est de mettre de la glace
la cryothérapie et même assez répandue
chez les sportifs de haut niveau pour se
préparer à l'effort ou récupérer plus
vite
il s'agit ici d'appliquer un froid très
intense sur le corps moins de 110 degrés
celsius quand même du coup si le froid
petite dose est bon pour la santé
c'est probablement que le problème avec
l'hiver vient d'ailleurs laissé le
problème de l'hiver ce n'était pas le
froid le premier problème en hiver c'est
vous pensez la saison des raclette
tartiflette et autres trucs bien lourd
tout ça manque quand même cruellement de
vitamines ça n'aide pas notre système
immunitaire à se saturer de gras et a
négligé les beaux fruits et légumes qui
de toute façon pas cette saison
en hiver c'est aussi rester au chaud
sous un plaid devant netflix
alors c'est pas netflix le problème
c'est plutôt de rester dedans à pieds
dedans sans trop aérien parce que merde
on se les cailler les radiateurs c'est
pas fait pour chauffer les armes
notre air intérieur est polluée à cause
de tous les produits qu'on utilise pour
nettoyer et embellir notre intérieur
entre le formaldéhyde contenu dans les
produits d'entretien ou les meubles en
agglo est l'acronyme de la bougie sont
bons nous poulets sont agressés en
permanence et ça complique d'autant plus
le travail de nos muqueuses et nos
petits poils de nez
la deuxième partie de l'équation c'est
qu'en hiver on a moins de lumière la
nuit ton plutôt l'angle avec lequel les
rayons du soleil nous arrive dessus est
plus grand et nous réchauffe - et ça ça
va poser beaucoup de problèmes
le monde du fait d'abord c'est un
véritable désinfectant gratuit les uv
agissent sur les virus en dézinguant
leur matériel génétique ce qui les rend
tout à fait inoffensif pour la plupart
le deuxième problème du manque de
lumière et physiologiques un des rouages
de notre système immunitaire passe par
la vitamine d ont la synthétise en
s'exposant au soleil une forme de
cholestérol sur notre peau et transformé
par les uv en pro vitamine d3 qui va se
transformer en vitamine d
or la vitamine d joue un rôle clé dans
la synthèse de la sérotonine
le neurotransmetteur clé de notre état
mental quand vous en manquez c'est le
coup de blues
c'est pour ça qu'en hiver ces baisses de
moral et dépression ce qu'on appelle le
winter blues plus on s'éloigne de
l'équateur et de son ensoleillement bien
bourrin plus le winter blues apparaît
tôt dans l'année
cet état de déprime va jouer sur votre
système immunitaire vous inciter à
rester sous la couette à manger un pot
de glace devant netflix les volets
fermés pour mieux voir votre écran et un
cercle vicieux s'enclenche alors en
norvège c'est un problème bien connu et
plus que récurrent il faut savoir qu'à
la latitude de ce beau pays
l'ensoleillement est en moyenne deux
fois plus faible qu'en france
métropolitaine
à tel point que la ville de rouge quand
commune de 3500 habitants encaissé dans
les montagnes à dépenser 600 10000 euros
pour installer plusieurs miroirs de 17
mètres carrés dirigeable par ordinateur
il renvoie la lumière du soleil sur la
place du marché pour aider les habitants
se sentir mieux le troisième et dernier
problèmes de l'hiver c'est l'humidité
associés l'humidité à la maladie n'est
pas totalement vrai quand l'air est
humide les gouttelettes d'eau dans
lesquels se trouvent les virus devienne
trop lourde pour rester en suspension
la gouttelette va rapidement tomber au
sol loubat le virus sera pas franchement
accès à votre nez ou vos yeux pour vous
infecter
a contrario de quand il fait froid
l'airé sec et contient moins d'humidité
facile de se promener à l'air libre
attention quand même un peu d'humidité
c'est bien trop non surtout quand il
pleut c'est pour cette raison qu'on
observe des épidémies dans les zones
tropicales pendant les périodes
pluvieuses
les scientifiques se penchent sur le
pourquoi du comment mais peut-être bien
que c'est les gouttes de pluie qui
projette les virus en l'air ça n'est pas
encore très bien compris mais on était
en berne les virus on tombe cinq fois
plus malade en hiver qu'en été
cet atys tic mais où sont les virus
pendant la saison chaude
ils prennent des vacances en réalité
lorsque les conditions ne leur sont pas
favorables et se planque
il s'installe dans ce qu'on appelle des
réservoirs ce sont les endroits où
s'accumulent les virus ce en un temps
dans deux points facteurs note le
premier réservoir suspectées seraient
nous mêmes les russes resterait en
sommeil dans notre corps en attendant
des conditions plus favorables pour se
répandre
ce mécanisme existe pour certains virus
comme celui d'hépatite b
mais ça a l'air d'être le cas pour la
grippe ou le rhume par contre il y a
continuellement des gens malades de la
grippe à travers le monde que ce soit à
la plage à côté de vous
dans l'hémisphère sud où les saisons
sont inversées
il fait froid quand il fait chaud ici
dans un monde mondialisé il est facile
de garder continuellement des souches
active maintenant des réservoirs prouver
on en connaît d'autres
d'abord les animaux les huttes par
exemple l'eau de mer est loin d'être
propre
une cuillère à café contient quasiment
plus de virus que d'habitants en inde
et c'est ainsi qu'on soupçonne les
huîtres d'être le réservoir de 80 % des
norovirus qui infecte l'homme et qui
provoque ainsi la gastro entérite
les oiseaux sauvages aussi régulièrement
les oiseaux d'élevage sont confinées
pour pas être en contact des oiseaux
migrateurs qui balade des souches de
grippe assez costaud genre à shine
troisième réservoir le sol les
conditions de température et d'humidité
ils sont plutôt stables dès qu'on
dépasse quelques centimètres de
profondeur
et ça c'est un gros problème en 2014 une
équipe de scientifiques a réussi à
réactiver un vieux virus de 30 mille ans
prisonnier dans les sols gelés
normalement c'est sol conserve des plans
des cadavres d'animaux et autres agents
infectieux pendant plusieurs milliers
d'années et quand le sol dégel les
ennuis commencent
en 2016 en sibérie les sports mortels
d'anthrax se sont libérés du cadavre
d'un rennes après le dégel cet épisode a
causé la mort de milliers de rennes et
d'un enfant un drame qui se répètent
actuellement des centaines de soldats et
de vétérinaires sont déployés en sibérie
pour stopper l'anthrax qui pourrait
ressurgir du passé dans ces sols gelés
se trouve aussi du pétrole des gaz et
les ressources minières maintenant
accessible puisque la glace font
l'appétit des industriels est grand mais
qui sait qu'elles menacent eux cadencés
sol gelé vieux de plusieurs millions
d'années
quel a été le premier moteur de
l'évolution humaine on peut penser au
climat à l'alimentation ou au
sociabilité entre humains tous ces
phénomènes font pâle figure face au
virus nous sommes des fils de virus
ils sont la cause de 30 % de tous les
changements meubles génome nos
chromosomes contiendrait 5 à 7% de
rétrovirus anciens gravé à jamais dans
notre adn
ce sont les moteurs de l'évolution un
exemple frappant est celui des
mammifères pour la
particularité de fabriquer du placenta
pour permettre la gestation
l'existence de ce placement a été rendue
possible grâce à l'infection par un
rétrovirus d'un animal ou aujourd'hui
disparu les rétrovirus qui touche
actuellement l'homme sont très dangereux
c'est le cas du virus du sida et de
certaines leucémies en 2016 on connaît
environ 20000 virus différents 2019 on
en comptait 200 milles et c'est pas des
nouveaux virus qui apparaît sens c'est
que la technologie permet de mieux en
mieux les identifier
la majorité de ces nouveaux virus ont
été découverts dans l'eau de mer car
c'est ce qu'on étudie actuellement mais
soyez certain qu'il y en a encore au
moins autant dans d'autres types
d'environnements entre l'augmentation
des températures les centres urbains
saturé et notre promiscuité plus grande
avec les animaux l'air dépens des bills
ne fait que commencer
il faudra apprendre à vivre avec a
évolué avec peut-être trop la naissance
d'un nouvel homme
l'homo virait en attendant n'hésitez pas
à vous abonner on espère atteindre les
500 milles avant la prochaine pandémie
plus sérieusement ça moi nous soutenir
et ça vous permet de suivre toutes les
semaines des nouvelles vidéos un gros
merci à julia un grand merci aux
monteurs un grand merci à toute l'équipe
allez les amis
[Musique]